you know the only thing worse than  someone who doesn't hold the door for  you when you're walking into a building  right behind them is when somebody holds  the door for you when you're too far  away I was at the gas station I was  practically just getting out of my car  like 25 Paces away and this guy looks  back sees that I'm heading towards the  door and holds it for me and I tried to  give him the wave and say no it's fine  go ahead just keep just keep going and  he gives me the way but I'll stand here  and so now it's just that awkward walk  where I have to do that sort of half jog  walk to get to the door faster than I  otherwise would have all for the sake of  me not having to just do this and open  it myself  I'm perfectly capable of doing that you  can just keep going